let's move on to the next session for
today's workshop and this session is
going to be
an overflow or overview of single cell
rna sequencing technology and we are
going to get introduced to uh
cell barcoding umi's
typical experimental overview of
experimental design and we are also
going to get introduced to typical
analysis pipeline where you will
pre-process quality control and
normalize the data and you can apply
dimensionality reduction and further
clustering of cells and differential
gene expression analysis performed for
the different cells and different types
of cells will help us understand the
biology behind the relevant questions
and relevant samples so
without further ado let's get started
and
we go on so this uh flows as a as a part
of our as a
with the foundation that you already
have some introduction to
bulk rna-seq analysis so if you do not
have such introduction so it is very
extremely worthwhile to check out the
transcriptomics data transcriptomic
course from our mixed logics platform
and once you are through with some sort
of basic with transcriptomics
course which
deals with bulk rna analysis methods and
understanding the logic behind them then
you can easily
get yourself promoted to uh
single cell rna sequencing and uh single
cell rna analysis method single cell uh
transcriptomics because
most of the information that we are
going to handle today and most of the
discussion that we are going to have
today and in general uh in single cell
rna's single cell transcriptomics
case will be in comparison with bulk
cell rna
transcriptomics on it so we learned that
in or we we already know from bulk cell
transcriptomics that
raw reads can be subjected to a sequence
of analysis methods and then we can
obtain a table of expression and then we
can use several visualization methods to
visualize this table of expression and
perform statistical analysis on this
table of expression and
you can also apply differential gene
expression analysis on this table of
expression and
etc so we are going to uh
find out what are the difference that we
are going to
get when we are subjecting the
reads or subtracting the
raw reads into a single cell rna
sequencing a single cell
rna-seq pipeline so um
let's
yeah
so in comparison with uh bulk cell rna
seek actually baltimore's sake will
actually allow us to measure the
abundance of messenger rnas as a
population average of all the cells in
the sample right this has certain
advantages but this also prevents us
from differentiating between changes in
regulation within the cells and also uh
it also helps prevents us from
understanding the composition or
heterogeneity within the sample of cells
so we will also lose
yeah we lose cell differentiation
information we lose cell heterogeneity
information and
we do not
also understand uh or we do not also
consider uh
eliminating some of the cells for their
um
for for their expression uh data being
an outlier compared to the other bulk um
cell transcriptonics pattern but in
single cell transcriptomics analysis it
actually helps us
to profile all the messenger rnas
present in one cell or present in single
cell cell by cell bases and this
constitutes the most widely used
profiling technology that we uh now know
as a c rna-seq technology so unlike
the bulk unlike its cousin bulk rna
sheet profiling the sequencing libraries
are generated from thousands and
thousands of cells um
in in bulk rna c profiling the single
cell rna technologies isolate each and
every cell
within these sequencing libraries and
then generate a cell specific sequencing
libraries or cell specific rna content
with cell specific molecular barcode so
the approaches of attaching a bar code
or attaching identifier codes to each
and every uh
every sample in our library will
actually help us in
counting or quantifying the expression
pattern um very efficiently and
without subjecting it to any biases that
we will discuss in
upcoming slides
so for both the approaches in general as
we just know will generate gene
expression estimates
at the cell level
but for the single cell technology it
actually uh
enables us to
measure the transcriptomic information
of
thousands and also sometimes millions of
cells in a
cell-by-cell basis environment so
so what does this
measurement will enable us to
understand or will enable us to study so
this
access to
transcriptomics information from
from the cells on a single cell
basis will actually help us to
understand the profiles
of these individual cells and to learn
about the cellular heterogeneity it will
also help us discover
new cell population or novel tissue
types and it will also help us order our
average cells within a developmental uh
trajectory to understand the different
differentiation
pathways and functionalities that govern
these developmental
trajectory of these cells
so to again sum up the difference
between bulk cell and iron single cell
in a uh
in a very short summary so uh
baltilla rna on a technical advancement
it replaced microarrays and and we know
that it has been widely used to measure
average expression levels of each gene
across a large population of cells in a
saturn so when you have a homogeneous
sample so
performing a bulk cell rnac
transcriptomics analysis to understand
the expression patterns of these samples
um gives you meaningful results and
meaningful understanding behind the
biology uh governing the biology of
these samples
but on the other hand when you have
single cell rnac
it actually measures the distribution of
expression level for each gene across
the population of cells so this
measurement of ah gene expression across
the different cell
types or different individual cell
resolution will actually allow us to
study
new biological questions which are cell
specific for example
as we already saw we can study
heterogeneity and we can study
differentiation and we can also study
the stochastic or the randomness of this
gene expression across the different
cellular population and we can also
study the inference of gene regulatory
networks across the cells for any given
condition for example um yeah and we
also see that uh
bulk rna seq studies often do not remove
outlier cells so if you have a cell that
does not belong to your multiple belong
to your
bulk of the cell or majority of the
samples then we have no way to remove
the expression values from this specific
or expression
quantification from this specific cell
but on the other hand single cellular
basic analysis in itself offer ways to
remove failed libraries and um and
[Music]
based on the percent of rhys map based
on the percentage of the mitochondrial
genome present and based on presence of
the different marker genes which we will
discuss in detail in the upcoming size
so these advantages and together with
the fact that we will get resolution of
expression pattern for each and every
cell
makes the single cell transcriptomics
analysis a very enticing
research field
so some of the major applications of
these research field which we already
touched on but uh
will give you uh for example
it can
help us understand new biological
questions like
cell specific changes in transcriptome
like cell cell type identification or
or cell differentiation along the
timeline or
some
random
expression uh patterns of the
uh of the gene uh and and their
distribution of expression patterns
across the different types of cells that
we are trying to understand and uh study
so these will form extremely important
part in understanding the
understanding the tissue types and how
they come together in forming
cell types and how they come together in
forming specific tissue types in general
so if i can summarize on the whole of uh
of uh
of a generic single cell transcriptomics
uh pipeline or analysis and
quantification then there are some
extremely important steps involved than
just
listing out some of the very important
steps we will
go through these steps one way
so first we have to extract the cells
from the tissue obviously and then from
this tissue we have to isolate the cells
as a as a single cell entity and this is
one of the extensive steps which can be
executed by ah involving different
technologies right and and we can
we will discuss
discuss an overview of these multiple
different technologies which offer us to
uh isolate single cell from this tissue
uh
samples so um
some steps follow ah
a typical rna-seq pipeline
that shares its
analysis
sequences with bulk rna analysis like
library preparation amplification of
these
mrnas and or dna cdnas and then
sequencing in general and then
generation of count metrics and then
followed by downstream analysis so
depending upon
the complexity of the data that we have
different downstream analysis can be
applied to identify different cell types
in the sample so we will apply uh
predominantly used downstream analysis
like sewerage analysis to identify novel
biomarkers or novel markers for
different cell types and we can also
subject these
the output of these single cell rna
pipeline to
to construct cell trajectories using uh
differentiation analysis from monocle uh
pipeline or monocle uh tool and uh yeah
and and likewise
so if you see or if if we uh um
consider single cell transcriptomics
from a technological standpoint so
single cell has been around since 2009
and and
so it is it's a fairly recent technology
but
given
given the amount of
cells that can be
explored from the beginning of 2009
until recently
we noted or we can note an exponential
increase in the scaling of single cell
iron basic in the past decade so
the technology is fast improving and the
ability to
isolate cells on a bulk level right
is
has developed enormously and this has
given rise to uh a new cousin or a new
analysis method which is spatial single
cell transcriptomics which has not been
uh which which is a very uh
important uh single cell technology and
single cell
analysis field research field that will
help us understand uh the tissue
heterogeneity and
cell
so for example
this is a this is an excellent review or
overview that is published in around
2017
and
this actually contains relevant
publications and it compiles an
interesting list of protocols
that can be automated or that can be
employed to
perform single cell rna-seq analysis or
single cell rna-seq
data collection in general
so when we uh
talk about
data preparation uh
and and
single cell rna
transcriptomics being different from
bulk cell rna transcriptonics and major
part of that difference actually comes
from
comes in the preparation of data so how
you can effectively separate the cells
for sequencing so there are methods that
can be categorized into different ways
but
two most important aspects
are the approaches to quantification and
the approaches to capturing cells
and isolating cells
as a single cell from the
tissues so for quantification we have ah
we have two uh approaches or two types
again we can quantify based on full
length of the reads and we can also
quantify based on the tags right the
quantification based on the full full
read length will actually tries to
achieve um
for
a uniform read coverage for each and
every transcript but
in contrast when we use a tag based
protocols we only capture either the
five prime end or we only capture either
the three prime end of each arrow so the
choice of this quantification method has
extremely important
implications in what types of analysis
that the data can be used for
in principle
a full-length protocol should provide an
even coverage of transcripts and we will
see or we shall see that there are often
biases in these coverages
one of the main advantages
of the tag based protocol is that they
can be combined with
molecular identifiers or unique
molecular identifiers which can help us
in avoiding these biases that arises
from this coverage and arises from uh
general uh amplitude application
amplification procedures right and this
will help us in improving the
quantification
accuracies
on the other hand ah being restricted to
one end of the transcript may actually
reduce
uh effectively the map ability and also
it might uh let make make it little bit
harder to distinguish between different
isoforms of the
of the genes so this generally the
strategy that is used for capture
determines the throughput and also it
determines what kind of additional
information besides sequencing that can
be obtained so um
while
uh
while choosing or opting for
the technology that that quantifies your
reads or quantifies your
quantifies to your mrnas you have to
make sure that you have
the kind of analysis also in your mind
as we see
since
umi based on tag-based technologies may
find it
difficult to distinguish specific
isoforms so if you have a sample
that in which you are expecting
different splice variants or different
isoforms of your cell of your genes then
it is better or it is better served if
you if you can um
make use of the full length protocols
instead of the umi based protocols or
tab-based approaches so there are
three uh
most widely used options for
isolating these cells into single cells
and they are micro well based approaches
and microfluidic based approaches and
dropless droplet based approaches so in
the first
micro well based approaches um
cells are actually isolated using
using a pipette or using a laser capture
and then placed into these fluidic wells
so these are microfluidic wells and
one of the major advantage of these
generic well-based methods is that they
can be
combined with
fluorescent activated cells
and making it possible to select cells
based on surface markers so that will
in turn help us
avoid heterogeneity in the cells or help
us avoid
selecting cells of specific types for
which we want to perform this analysis
and this strategy is extremely useful
for situation where as i mentioned one
want to isolate a specific subset of
cells for sequencing another advantage
is that one can take pictures of the
cells also which can be used to
which can provide an additional
modality and useful applications to
quantify
the cells and uh and to tag or to
identify damaged cells or identify
doublets in a specific microbial and
etcetera
so some of the drawbacks of this method
is that they are often low throughput
and the amount of work a required
personal may be really
considerable and and
it is not worth
doing such an analysis for a large
number of samples so if you have a very
low uh very few
samples and if you want to perform these
analysis that can be extremely useful
but when you have hundreds and hundreds
of
cells in a in in your tissues or in your
samples then it might not be worth
performing this analysis um
using manual labor or using any other
form
so
on the other hand microfilament
platforms such as
[Music]
fluid in c1 will actually provide an
integrated system for capturing the
cells and for carrying out reactions
that is necessary for all the laboratory
preparations that you will need to
you will need to
perform sequencing so
since
they provide these
provider integrated system for this
for the selection of cells and also for
carrying out reaction they are often
high throughput or higher throughput
compared to the microbial based platform
so
typically only around ten percentage of
the cells that you uh give as an input
or that you take
from the sample are actually captured in
microfluidic platform and
and hence uh they are not extremely uh
useful and not very appropriate when
when when we are dealing with rare cell
types or when we are dealing with cells
with very small number of inputs or
tissue types that that has
that is extremely heterogeneous in
nature but
moreover generally uh from uh from
from a financial point of view the chips
that are used are relatively expensive
but
uh
but since the reactions that
that actually help us prepare this
library can be carried out in much
smaller volume uh finance can be uh made
up and money can be received on the
reality agents
and
so
one of the most popular uh method to
isolate these cells into a single cells
is the droplet based methods right and
these method will actually encapsulate
each and individual cell inside a nano
liter droplet that
that is that is present together with
the b
the bead is actually loaded with the
enzymes and
these enzymes will actually construct
the library so in particular each bead
will in addition to this enzyme will
contain a unique barcode which will be
attached to all the reeds originating
from that specific cell
thus
all of these droplets can be pulled and
sequenced together and the reeds can
subsequently
subsequently be categorized and assigned
to the cells of origin based on these
specific barcodes that we put in to each
and every one of these piece
so
these droplet based platforms typically
have the highest throughput uh
compared to the other two methods and
and
since the library preparation is
is uh
is carried out at the nano liter
level and and the costs are extremely
low and the agent costs are extremely
low and that compensates for the
availability of the system that requires
more and more financial investment
so um
when we use these microfluidics based
method they are
because of their high throughput output
and because of their because of the
ability to automate their systems we can
we can apply these
in large scale for single cell rna basic
uh transporting methods and there are
five basic steps
before the analysis commences
to obtain or to carry out these
microfluidics based methods and they are
first we have to
suspend or suspension of cells from a
complex tissue to isolate cells so this
this is carried out in the
uh in the droplet-based method assay
just as we just discussed and then uh we
will synthesize primers using bar coded
primer b that attaches itself uh two
different cell types and then the
microfluidic device will then capture
cells in the oil droplets with the
barcoded beads inside
and once the beads are once the library
is
triplet then the cells are lysed and
so not not once the library is prepared
once the
droplets captures the cells and then the
cells are lysed and their rna is
actually hybridized with these beads and
this actually generates a single cell
transcript forms attached to the micro
particles that we
put in this put in these droplets and
they are called stamps
and these stamps are then amplified in
the pcr and once these stamps are
amplified
then we subject that to sequencing and
the sequencing analysis or sequencing
actually produces
read counts and
um i counts so
depending upon the kind of analysis or
the kind of library that we prepared and
these are the
counts that these are the table or
structure data
that we use for
further
downstream analysis methods